the most important question is how is
your health because i know you said that
you
had covid i did um
i got it back in march with my wife we
share everything
yeah and uh i you know at the time
i didn't think that it was important
that another celebrity come out and say
hey i got kovid
so i just didn't say anything um
and and that was until i was giving
plasma
um for others who had got it
really bad and um the phlebotomist
uh was saying can you post a video of
you donating and maybe others will
donate as well because the donor list
has dropped off significantly and i
thought okay
now this is a good reason to out myself
and say here's what happened i was very
fortunate
um please be responsible and if you had
it and you have the antibodies
consider donating um that was the
message
i was trying to convey and and that you
know
one of positive positivity that we could
get through this
but we have to work together we have to
be brothers and sisters in humanity
and be mutually respectful and say i
don't want anyone else to get sick
um please wear a mask and i will too
yeah i love that and i appreciate that
you came out with that
and sharing that with people um what is
it
about fascinating gorillas that
continues to capture our hearts
doing some of this research i was down
in uh disney kingdom in orlando and i
met some of the gorillas there they are
enormous
yes ferocious territorial
and i and we had tutorials of how to
deal you know don't make eye contact
just keep down
else they'll think you're a threat so
i'm my my heart is beating and they're
very close um yes
i had to just you know calm myself and
wow this is
this energy is so enormous um
but they're fascinating animals and this
is an
incredibly uh true story uh
that we're very proud of and it's
where it's fun it's it's heartfelt
you'll laugh you'll cry
it's great for for kids you know and
from 6 to
96 and so i was eager to do a family
uh story that you can really multi
generations can sit around and
enjoy it equally at the same time and
this really is it
and also at the end of it we're hoping
that
just by asking the question maybe
kids will ask the question too like is
it right for us
to keep animals in captivity what about
zoos and
what's where should where do we come out
on that and we don't try to answer that
for anyone but
pose the question and it's all
legitimate and so hopefully a
conversation
will start after kids watch that uh one
and only ivan
you